donc la biafine pour les patients brûlés
il ya des compresses stériles
[Musique]
des cartons remplis de médicaments
cela fait des jours que merouane mais
c'est qu'hier les empilent interne au
chu de toulouse mais roanne est aussi
président de médical up
créée le 10 août dernier son association
propose de faire des dons de médicaments
et de produits sanitaires pour aider
l'algérie à faire face à la pandémie de
kobe 19 et au violent incendie qui la
touche depuis plusieurs jours un appel
rapidement entendu
les réponses des toulousains étaient
vraiment rapides donc nous avons
commencé à récupérer des dons dès le
jour on a lancé cet appel aux dents et
les gens continuent de venir tous les
jours soit pour donner sur place soit il
on voit par voie postale des chèques ou
des dons matériels
en une semaine l'association a récolté
un très grand nombre de dons un local de
20 mètres carrés ainsi déjà été remplies
et un troisième centre de collecte de
dons a été ouvert ce lundi hakima denis
s'est porté volontaire pour le tenir
giran d'une brasserie à toulouse il
laisse à disposition son établissement
pour y entreposer les dons avant qu'il
soit envoyé en algérie
rapidement l'idée de faire quelque chose
pour pour pour la kabylie pour l'algérie
en général est venu et finalement c'est
l'association qui a pris contact avec
moi pour me dire qu'il cherchait un
endroit pour entreposer des médicaments
des dents et comme on est si tu es
vraiment centre ville c'était avec un
grand plaisir que j'ai accepté et que
j'essaie de les aider à
collecter ces médicaments et
à aider les nôtres en algérie comme
toulouse de nombreuses villes ont
rejoint le mouvement plusieurs cagnotte
ont également été créés et celle de
merouane avait pour objectif 650000
euros une somme presque déjà atteinte en
à peine une semaine merci beaucoup